-Our next guest
is a very funny comedian
you know
from "Saturday Night Live"
as well as movies such as
"Sisters" and "Wine Country."
She's starring in the upcoming
Broadway Show "POTUS:
Or, Behind Every Great Dumbass
are Seven Women
Trying to Keep Him Alive,"
which will open
at the Shubert Theatre
on April 27th.
Please welcome back to the show
our very dear friend
Rachel Dratch, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome, Dratch!
You have --
-Hello!
-I am already in your debt
in life in general,
but you did us a favor tonight.
You showed up as a sort of --
you filled in for
a last-minute guest hole,
and thank you so much.
-Yes, I love to take up
a guest hole.
[ Laughter ]
No, yeah, I got a call
not too long ago,
and I like to think of myself
as your Teri Garr.
-That is a very important role.
-For those of you
who used to watch "Letterman."
-Every talk show host needs
their Teri Garr, though --
someone they can trust,
who can show up, can deliver.
-Yes.
Now, let me say that
I was making chili
when I got this call,
so I was cooking onions,
so I might smell like onions.
-Okay, that's all right.
We do appreciate you
putting that caveat out there.
-Okay, good.
-Hey, you know what
I was thinking when Mariska
and Chris were out here?
I think one of my first
or second weeks at "SNL,"
you wrote a sketch called
"Law & Order: SUV."
-I did?
-You did.
-I don't remember
half the stuff I did.
What was it?
-It was --
I think it was basically
just SUV-related crimes.
-Really? I wrote that?
[ Laughter ]
-Look at you!
-I guess I did!
-This is one of the new things
we're trying with guests
where I tell you
something about you.
[ Laughter ]
-God,
I don't remember doing that.
I mean, I remember the sketch.
I didn't remember --
Okay.
Anyway, let's move on from that.
-Okay. You, um --
[ Laughter ]
You might not know this --
you're in a Broadway show.
-I am!
I do know that.
-That's so exciting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, I've seen you --
I've seen you onstage before,
but I'm not sure --
I did not realize
this is your Broadway debut.
-Broadway debut, yes.
It's a farce with seven women,
written by a woman,
directed by Susan Stroman,
written -- Selina Fillinger
is the playwright.
She's a young,
up-and-coming playwright
who got her play on Broadway.
-That's amazing.
-And it's me and --
I mean, I hope I remember
everyone right now,
but Vanessa Williams,
Julie White, Lea DeLaria,
Lilli Cooper,
Suzy Nakamura from Second City,
our buddy, and --
oh, my God --
Julianne Hough!
-Wow!
Nice catch -- you got them all.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's really exciting.
-Yeah.
-And this was -- is it safe to
say that even before comedy,
theater was your thing?
You were in an early -- you were
in a production of "Music Man."
-I was, in high school.
-So, this is
a high school production?
-That's me in "Music Man"
as Amaryllis.
-Okay.
-I did have --
This is from the yearbook,
and I noticed
I left my watch on by accident.
[ Laughter ]
So that's kind of anachronistic.
-That's how it gives away
the con, right?
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
But that was
the dress rehearsal.
I did take it off
for the real show.
But anyway, yes, that was me
in "The Music Man"
in my junior year
of high school, yeah.
-Amaryllis is the young girl
who's taking piano lessons.
-Yeah, so it's not a major role.
-Did you have to do a lot of,
like, miming playing piano,
do you remember?
-Well, I actually played
the piano, Seth, so...
-Oh! Well!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean, it's just a little --
like, anyone could learn that.
But anyways, yeah,
so I've done theater a lot,
but I've always gravitated
towards comedy.
So, you know,
this is like, whatever.
This is gonna be fun because --
-Have you seen "The Music Man"
on Broadway?
-I did see it, yes.
-Was it exciting?
-Yeah. Oh, my gosh,
'cause I know all the songs.
When you go to a show that you
were in, then you're, like,
singing along in your seat,
much to the chagrin
of your seatmates.
[ Laughter ]
But no, yes, I saw "Music Man."
It was super fun.
-We talked about your son Eli,
who is now 11 1/2,
which is amazing.
-Yes, yes.
-I remember seeing him
in a stroller,
because he wasn't always 11 1/2.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You talked about bringing him
to Broadway shows.
My wife just brought our oldest
to "Lion King," which he loved.
You talked about bringing Eli
to "Fiddler on the Roof."
-I did, yeah.
-And what was his review, again?
-Well, he said it was boring
and sad and boring.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But so,
I've brought him to more,
like, kid-friendly musicals.
I don't want you to think
I threw him in
on "Fiddler on the Roof."
But as I told you last time
I was here -- whatever --
yeah, like,
"Fiddler on the Roof" --
I used to love that --
Like, I saw it when I was
little, and I really loved it,
and I wanted him to see it,
but it didn't go over
so great with him, yeah.
-Do you think -- Did you --
In the watching it,
did you realize early on, "Oh,
I've made a terrible mistake"?
-Yes, yes.
Because it was kind of, like,
dark sets, and, like,
it wasn't really, like,
a lot of, you know,
real-life-looking stuff.
And then, I also realized, like,
"Oh, yeah, this play is kind of
about, like, marrying someone
outside of your religion."
He was like 6,
so it wasn't exactly a child --
but I think -- now I'm just
repeating another segment I did.
But he did lean over to me
partway through and be like,
"I wanna go."
[ Laughter ]
And then one of the characters
onstage said,
"I have to leave you now,"
and he leans over,
and he goes,
"I have to leave this show."
[ Laughter ]
So, that's a rewind
of another Seth segment.
-Hey, look, sometimes
when you're Teri Garr --
-When you're filling in, you got
to go play the hits, right?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-So, wait.
Are you gonna bring --
Will Eli come to this show?
-Okay.
So this show has a lot,
a lot of salty language in it.
-Oh, okay.
-Really, really.
So, I don't know, 'cause
he's heard a lot of swears --
-How salty?
-Like, think saltiest.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-No, he's heard a lot of,
like, bad words,
but I don't know that I want to
introduce him to new bad words.
But I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
We'll see,
'cause then I'm also, like,
"Well, I want him to see it,
so maybe I'll just, like,
have a little sit-down
and lay down the --
-That's so interesting because
I think there's no way
to stop your kids
hearing the bad words,
but you don't want it
to be by your hand.
-Exactly.
And then do you want him
to go tell everyone in the fifth
grade about the new word?
Yeah.
-And like, he heard --
"I know this because I saw my
mom say it on a stage."
-Well, actually, I don't say it.
-Oh, there you go.
So maybe
when the night he comes,
every time someone
says a bad word, you, like,
do a big thing
of rolling your eyes.
-Yeah, or I'm like,
"Wasn't me, wasn't me."
[ Laughter ]
No, but the show is very funny.
So, I start out --
Like, the character that I play
is really fun 'cause I start out
as someone who's very, like,
buttoned-up and apologetic.
Like, I can really relate to
that being, like, "Oh, my God.
did I do this right?"
that kind of thing.
But then the character
goes on a journey,
and I get to do
a lot of crazy things.
So, yeah.
I was thinking,
if you like me as an actor,
you'll really like this show.
And then, if you don't like me,
there's a lot of other ladies
there that you might be fans of.
[ Laughter ]
-What a wonderful --
-Put that on the marquee.
"If you hate Rachel Dratch,
there are six others
that you might enjoy."
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I think I'm gonna like
all seven of you.
Thanks so much for showing up,
for bailing us out.
It is always such a joy
to see you.
Rachel Dratch!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"POTUS" officially opens
on Broadway April 27th.